and just to let you know the candidates
who are running in Kensington they are
Jay Austin Cahoon for the brexit Party
Jack Bravo as an independent fisty
Buchan for the Conservative Party and we
don't code for the Labour Party it's got
door for the workers Revolutionary Party
Herot golf or touch love world wide UK
sound jima for the Liberal Democrats 15
little sign for the Green Party and
Roger Phillips for the Christian
People's Alliance now politics is
usually dominated by the two big parties
but as you can see from that candidate
list elections give a chance for smaller
parties to make their pitch to voters as
well joining us now is the leader of one
of such party the greens' party's
co-leader sean barie thank you so much
for being with us
today now I'm keeps kind of get onto
your policy offer but first I just want
to get any reaction you might have had
to the story that we're doing with this
morning the interview with Prince Andrew
I don't if you most watch any of it I've
seen parts of it and I think it is
really important that people at all
levels have to answer questions to
allegations like this the the meeting
movement it's throwing up so many
instance of women being exploited and
abused by men in positions of power and
when there are allegations like this
they do need answering no matter who
someone is do you think the royal family
in particular need to be more
accountable sometimes I think they need
to be as accountable as anybody else and
I think it's right that he has answered
these questions on the interview
although I wasn't particularly convinced
I think we need to hear more from him on
this as well do you think he should have
apologized perhaps for his friendship
with someone who is a convicted sex
offender yeah it wasn't a very
empathetic interview if that's if that's
like a thing to say with the victims and
I yeah I think he should have been more
apologetic and and and taken more
responsibility for for some of the
things that his friend was doing and
potentially talk more about the women
the girls who exactly yeah they were
they were very much not part this
thinking I think okay thank you and for
for that now let's move on shall we to
the election campaign and Green Party
because I'm interested in some of the
spending pledges that you've been making
because it does look like we're having
quite a high spending election on all
sides but the Green Party in particular
and for example pledged to spend a
hundred billion pounds every year to
tackle climate change how are you gonna
fall
yes well I mean it's good that all the
parties now are saying essentially the
austerity was a mistake that we need to
invest in the country and we need to
invest in people the infrastructure
needed to sort out climate change and we
are the only party really putting
forward the right figures for that and
now you know why because you can catch
up on the last 20 or 30 years my whole
lifetime is everything to do this it can
be paid for there's there's a low
borrowing rate at the moment we think
that the servicing cost of this debt can
be managed through revenue and it's just
what's needed on that point there is a
load borrowing rate of the minute
but if ambassadors and lenders look
herps a future government proposals and
see they're going to be borrowing
billions and billions and billions of
pounds more that borrowing rate it's
going to go up isn't it because I will
think that the UK has a bigger risk of
defaulting when they look at what we're
spending the money on we are investing
in a more resilient economy we're
investing in green energy in homes that
cost less to heat in warmer home so
healthier people in the population we're
investing in new jobs which will start
paying back in taxes soon afterwards
these are really really good investments
this is like the opposite of a black
hole it's about building a stronger
country right into the future and
assuring that we do have the future that
that the young people today will not
forgive us if we do not build so this is
it's playing catch-up it's a lot of
money but it's what's absolutely needed
and and we're the ones who are holding
all the other parties to account on
their spending pledges as well we can
say you know with confidence that the
Conservatives
aren't doing enough their labour
spending pledges aren't enough that the
Liberal Democrats are going nowhere near
as far as they should because we're the
the Green Party we invented the green
new deal over ten years ago we've been
saying this for 30 years I mean I'm not
talking about what you're spending the
money on and what the rights and wrongs
all about I'm just talking about the
amount of money you're talking about and
the IFS example calculating the Greens
proposals will take barone to 140
billion pounds I just want to show you
one graph as well this is research that
The Times carried out yesterday and this
is the party spending pledges so far
that they've calculated so the Lib Dems
on 193 billion conservatives 210 billion
labor and 473 billion and then you got
the Green Party or nine hundred and
fifty nine billion I mean I'm okay you
might not be expecting to be
government but come on well half of that
is our great New Deal spending over the
time and the miscalculation and one of
the other policies I mean we are putting
forwards big ideas every day in this
election we are we water guys one of the
things we announced this week was the
the idea of a basic income for every
citizen now this is something else that
cost money but it's it's the parallel to
the to the green you deal spending
ability in people and the time you've
overestimated the cost of that so that
isn't quite as high as it would say but
I'm not gonna mess about we are planning
to invest an awful lot in this country
over the next ten years because it is
needed we do have to transform the
economy we do have to completely change
a lot of our systems I mean you look at
our manifesto later in the week we'll be
talking about transforming our democracy
as well the way our communities work the
Greens have been putting forward big
ideas for 30 years people need to start
listening to us now or seen it'll be too
late
one of your policies at that you've
released today is this idea to increase
the minimum wage and again it's it's a
policy that many people really like the
liquor but if you look at the numbers
it's a big increase that you're
proposing to the minimum wage here
you're tripling the minimum wage for 16
year-olds doubling it 18 year-olds
employees will have to pay an extra
three pounds 79 is an hour for people
over 25 I mean first on small businesses
they're just going to cut jobs aren't
they our policies towards small
businesses are across the board very
positive for small businesses but these
are again this is what people need in
order to live a decent life if you're a
small business owner you might not be
able to fold it I mean there are other
policies will be positive for businesses
for businesses for example where we're
looking in London at defining a working
rent businesses are stuck with huge
rents and business rates and will help
the one that score whilst helping their
workers - with this new right but it's
completely unjust that people under 25
can be paid a literal pittance for the
same work that someone older does and
the government way of calculating what
they call a living wage is not correct
it is not a living wage and so we are
saying we would make sure everybody was
paid 12 pounds an hour by 2022 and it
would not discriminate against you
workers in the way that it doesn't I
mean some of our viewers won't be
listening to what you're saying
and think this is just typical
opposition politics these are the kind
of fancy ball balls the party can put
forward if you don't really think you
can have to work out how the Sun set up
we're quite serious about greens the new
green MPs who are going to be in
Parliament having a big influence on the
next government this is all about
working with other parties in opposition
to get them to take up our ideas and all
of these ideas of things that we think
the other parties should be adopting
some of them are doing it already and in
little bits and pieces but I think
having a strong green voice in
Parliament pushing for these ideas is
going to be the outcome of this election
and I'd really think things some of our
key seats particularly where we've
cooperated with other parties we've
demonstrated the grown-up politics that
greens can do and we'll do that after
the election as well we'll be putting
the case for these policies putting it
as a business case for these policies
the social case the environmental case
and people will be coming in talking
about your candidates and how many MPs
do you think is realistic that the MP
that the Green Party could win at this
election at the moment we're focusing on
11 seats the 10 within the cooperative
agreement that we made with pleiku
Murray and the Liberal Democrats we're
really proud of that agreement and the
fact that there are key seats now where
Greens standing is the strongest so you
remain leader gets elected and then the
other seat is Sheffield where we've got
very very strong Green Party we've been
talking about trees policies this week
greens on the council they have been
defending the trees against the Labour
Council we think we should so you think
you could win 11 seats it's not I mean
it obviously I feel battle if you look
at what happened in 2015 when we were in
the middle of a green surge as well in
Bristol West which is the seat week we
concentrated on we managed the 23
percent swings so we can make big swings
Green Green members are very fired up
for this election there's a lot of
attention on some of the some of the
really new things we're doing you know
not just working with other parties
under unites remain but the big ideas
were putting for is the influence we've
had on other parties I think all of that
means it is possible for us to get big
swings in lots of different place
talking about working across party and
you mentioned the remain alliance
when you've identified the 60 seats
where only one candidate from the Greens
the Lib Dems and plica Murray will stand
to give a remained candidate the best
chance of winning that seat there's been
a bit of upset hasn't that on that among
some people in your party on the green
left movement for example you're unhappy
with working with the Liberal Democrats
because of some of those policies in
coalition are you worried that by doing
this you're basically just propping up
the Lib Dems you may as well just be
another branch of them well it's
definitely not a merger maybe we look we
work on various councils with both the
Lib Dems and Labour somewhere like the
Forester ding for example or sourced
routes indeed so we were able to work
with other parties in different ways we
don't agree with the Liberal Democrats
on everything you've seen Caroline Lucas
criticizing their revoked position I'm
very critical about their very limited
spending plans you know they would be
arguing essentially to continue
austerity but this is what grown-up
politics is about you don't it's not
difficult in the Gaucher with people you
agree with all the time it is difficult
to sit down with people you don't agree
with and do something that's actually in
the interests of the the wider country
and that's what we've done within the
party
all the decisions were made by local
parties democratically we we consulted
all our members before we even started
talking to other parties and our
democratic structures in the centre the
governance bodies signed everything off
so it was all done in the right way and
you know people who don't share the
majority of you may perfectly free to be
unhappy about that but I mean a majority
view within the party is this is the
right thing to do in this election just
finally and we've seen floods devastate
some parts of the country recently and
with 24 hours of rainfall going on I
mean it's not in the headlines as much
but there's the this flood warnings
across the Midlands and the north are
still so sea of red people are still in
terrible trouble and risk of more
flooding happen I mean are you linking
mister climate change we have to
acknowledge that the climate scientists
are telling us these kinds of events
will become more common as climate
change progresses and they they are
being you know we've these are places
that were flooded in 2007 millions were
span in
in fish lake on flood defences which are
now failing again the way to fix this is
further upstream we can't just be
putting in heavy engineering we have to
fix the land the entire river catchments
again natural flood risk management is
something Greene's been pioneering
particularly where we've got councillors
and particularly where we've got
influence over land management in in
sort of County Council's as well these
are things that people are playing
catch-up on and it's it's prevention
rather than dealing with this kind of
tragedy that happens to people's homes
that we need to be focusing on okay
thank you very much coming to the studio
today let's appreciate it